[Música]
en parís en la primera casa de francia
es la más vista la más famosa la más
prestigiosa el salón de baile del elíseo
mil metros cuadrados tapicería del siglo
18 frescos del techo catalogados lámpara
de cristal de baccarat además de las
conferencias de prensa y las cenas
oficiales la investidura del presidente
de la república tiene lugar aquí desde
el general de gaulle hasta emmanuel
macrón todos han hecho un juramento
histórico en este majestuoso salón que
ha permanecido en su estado original por
más de un siglo pero que ahora se está
marchitando para darle una segunda vida
a este excepcional lugar pronto
comenzará una completa remodelación y es
la de la arquitecta isabel stanislas a
quien se le encargó la obra
la idea de cambiar la sala no es
necesariamente una idea estética se
tendrá una necesidad porque había una
filtración de agua que apareció allí en
atrás de los primeros capaces que
tuvieron que hacer es reparado aquí por
ejemplo están las figuras que empiezan a
decir a echar
hoy en día realmente no podemos
permitirnos dejar eso así es realmente
parte de nuestro patrimonio está
hablamos
bateman 150 de los mejores artesanos del
mundo participan tienen 8 semanas ni una
más para trasladar la sala de fiestas
del siglo 19 al siglo 21 aquí estamos
hacemos un primer tapiz colgante vamos a
bajar primero y luego los tres grandes
tapices bíblicos del lado del sena
protestan se quita la alfombra y se
desenganchan las cortinas casi dos mil
metros de telas de seda y satén hay
alguien ahí abajo no no hay nadie allí
se ve bien allá va castillos ministerios
embajadas estos artesanos están
acostumbrados a trabajar en los lugares
más prestigiosos es algo importante para
mí porque el salón de baile fue mi
primer trabajo como jefe de taller
y cuando volvemos a nuestra carrera y lo
hace bien
el esquí y luego es la obra que ven
todos los clases en la televisión es un
dijo schell así que todos los franceses
en nuestro trabajo
entonces si es importante el mobiliario
nacional alberga la más noble de las
artesanías francesas ya sea que esté
hecho de madera bronce o tela el objeto
es aquí limpiado restaurado sublimar
para las nuevas cortinas del salón de
fiestas la arquitecta pudo elegir entre
los 48.000 colores diferentes de la
carta de colores para alfombras y
tapetes hay un armario mágico isabel
stanislas pasó tres días aquí para
elegir los tonos de la futura alfombra
de taxis o de escogimos unos grises
ligeramente más fríos en realidad y
luego nos vimos con tonos mucho más
suave más nutridos y aquí está su
elección un monocromo de gris y otro de
amarillo puede ver todas las sutilezas
de los colores y ver cómo se combinan
realizaciones en este proyecto de
remodelación
en el taller de tapicería está en
primera fila durante varios meses los
costureros han estado ocupados cortando
cosiendo y ajustando hoy el primer telón
está casi terminado y su chef logko bien
no deja pasar nada no pusiste la grapa
en la costura verdad a usted de ambos
lados
no el primero es siempre importante
porque es lo que marcará la pauta para
el resto de la prenda cuando tienes
problemas para hacer la primera te dices
a ti mismo que va a tomar mucho tiempo
mientras que cuando va bien es bueno
para tu corazón iba directo al resto
allí estuvo bien
a unas pocas calles de distancia otros
artesanos también tienen el oro a su
alcance como el log mail oradora de la
mundialmente famosa me pongo a eldorado
una técnica que no ha cambiado durante
siglos
he venido a cortar la hoja a la medida
estoy aquí para obtener la electricidad
estática de la piel y así poder agarrar
la sábana y ponerla en el soporte
[Música]
tan pronto como se coloca la hoja de
horas desempolvada y luego unas pocas
pinceladas son suficientes para revelar
su brillo acabo de presionar la hoja
gracias a la joven el salón de baile
recuperará algo de su brillo de vuelta
al palacio del elíseo es la recta final
y la hora de la verdad para los
tapiceros después de meses de
confeccionar las
si no bien tenemos que volver al taller
tenemos que volver a hacerlo siempre es
un poco estresante
si bien una sonrisa es habitual para la
arquitecta todos los elementos de la
decoración deben encajar lo aprobamos
son muy muy buenas noticias es
emocionante y casi quiero poner todo
ahora mismo pero no vamos a hacerlo si
me a matanza un poco más adelante el
aura me aplica meticulosamente el dorado
que realzará los medallones con las
iniciales de la república lo que estamos
dorando ahora puedes durar cientos de
años le ponemos mucho corazón y luego
decimos hay un pequeño toque de nuestras
manos que se queda aquí
sí sí sí unos días después se levantó el
telón en el salón de baile queda
transformado y muestra su modernidad
gracias a la excelencia del saber hacer
francesa
[Música]